i love building apis on cloud run  because it gives me auto scaling and i  only pay when my code is handling a  request  but sometimes i write full web apps  which contain both a server api and  client assets like html files  firebase hosting is a great option for  serving those static assets as it  includes a global cdn  but you can also use cloudrun itself if  you don't mind going without a cdn  simply tell your web application  framework in your code that a particular  directory contains static files to be  served to the client if requested  why would you do this  well it simplifies coding as you don't  have to deal with course when javascript  and api calls are in the same domain it  simplifies deployments as the full web  app is deployed within a single  container  i use this approach for company internal  web apps where ease of coding and ease  of deployment are more important than  global scalability  happy coding